bien bonjour à tous alors je présente
cette cette table ronde à la suite des
rvert on a donc autour de nous Claude
Greff que vous connaissez qui est député
de d'indr Loir qui était secrétaire
d'État chargé de la famille
et comme nous pensons qu'il faut pas
discuter uniquement entre élu on a tenu
aussi à invité Philippe RAMBAL qui est
dans le cabinet de conseil
ernong directeur des affaires des
affaires publiques le sujet de notre
tableau ronde c'est de s'interroger
ensemble sur la question de
l'efficacité du gouvernement au reg
regard des attentes des Français pas le
gouvernement actuel le gouvernement de
manière
générale première remarque on en a
beaucoup parlé les uns et les autres on
tient la 5e République on n'est pas du
tout en train de se projeter vers une 6e
république qui est souvent d'ailleurs
réduite à l'état de slogan on tient la
5e République c'est-à-dire à l'élection
au suffrage universel direct du
président de la République qui a donc la
légitimité populaire et nationale pour
nommer un gouvernement qui est lui-même
responsable devant l'Assemblée nationale
c'est ça le cœur du réacteur de la 5e
République on y tient on n'est pas ici
partisan d'une espèce de de de
bouleversement et d'improvisation
constitutionnelle la 5èe elle a tenu
elle a tenu y compris dans des R
parfois de cohabitation avec une
majorité de l'Assemblée nationale
différente de la majorité présidentielle
elle a tenu le choc et on y tient encore
plus au moment où il y a des tempêtes
menaces de dislocation du continent
européen sorte de dépression nationale
bref on tient le sature de la 5è et
c'est donc dans ce cadre qu'on
s'interroge de manière très pratique
très pragmatique sur l'efficacité
c'estàdire sur la capacité à obtenir des
résultats
s'agissant du gouvernement s'agissant
donc de l'exécutif il y a au moins deux
questions qu'on a envie de se poser de
vous poser la première question c'est
quelque chose qui parfois est pas perçu
d'ailleurs par l'opinion publique mais
qui est pourtant très important c'est
qu'il y a eu dans les 25 dernières
années beaucoup de démembrement du
pouvoir exécutif pour le dire autrement
le pouvoir exécutif a renoncé lui-même à
exercer son pouvoir dans bien des
domaines de l'action de publique c'est
ce qu'on appelle les autorités
administratives indépendantes les AAI et
elles ont été
multipliées il y a eu beaucoup
d'agences d'organismes de commission de
comités et on a tendance à
penser queelas Sarkozi tout à l'heure le
dira avec beaucoup plus de clarté qu'il
faut
probablement réduire le périmètre de ces
autorités
administrative indépendante alors ça
veut dire concrètement que certaines
d'entre elles pourront être sans doute
fusionné je prends un exemple concret
vous avez l'acnil d'un côté la CADA de
l'autre qui sont deux institutions qui
ont leur intérêt à l'heure du numérique
tous les documents administratif sont de
plus en plus numériques ça aurait du
sens que knil et cada fassent une seule
autorité par exemple il y a comme ça pas
mal de sujets concrets qui nécessite
d'être revu ça produira un certain
nombre d'économies budgétaire mais
surtout ça redonnera au gouvernement la
capacité de gouverner dans des domaines
d'action publi où il doit exercer son
autorité de même s'agissant du
gouvernement on pense vraiment on va en
débattre mais que il faut pas que les
préfets soit dépossédés des différents
services de l'État là il y a un énorme
sujet le préfet c'est pas simplement le
monsieur qui porte un bel uniforme et
qui met des
gerbes lors des cérémonies patri otique
il faut continuer à le faire ça doit
être le patron des services de l'État
dans son territoire et ça veut dire
notamment que les préfets de département
de notre point de vue doivent pas
uniquement être responsable de la
sécurité publique ils doivent aussi
avoir une vraie capacité de décision
d'impulsion d'entraînement sur des
services qui sont parfois complètement
dispersés les dral les desdte et ceter
et ceeta voilà on on pense vraiment que
il y a un sujet là qui qui est important
y compris pour les élus parce qu'il faut
avoir un interlocuteur et il faut que le
préfet encore une fois est des leviers
troisème point puis je vais m'arrêter là
on s'interroge
beaucoup et donc ça sera bien d'avoir
l'avis de la salle et l'avis aussi des
des de l'ensemble des adhérents qui
comme d'habitude seront consulté par par
un questionnaire on s'interroge beaucoup
sur les grands postes de au
fonctionnaires il faut pas naturellement
avoir une défiance à l'endroit de la
fonction publique public ni de la haute
fonction publique un gouvernement il a
besoin de s'appuyer sur des techniciens
il a besoin de servicees qui soi dirigés
bien évidemment mais ce que nous pensons
c'est
que il faut jamais oublier qui a la
légitimité la légitimité elle provient
de l'élection du Président de la
République et de l'Assemblée nationale
ensuite le président de la République il
nomme le gouvernement c'est l'article 8
le gouvernement il est responsable de la
politique de la nation c'est article 20
et les grands postes c'est l'article 13
de la Constitution c'est le président de
la République qui nomme ce que nous
avons envie de dire c'est que il serait
normal après l'élection du Président de
la République que les grands postes de
haut
fonctionnaires soient tous remis à
plat c'est beaucoup plus transparent de
dire ça techniquement ça voudrait dire
qu'une loi organique définirait le
nombre l'identité très précise des des
postes poste de préfet poste de grand
directeur d'administration centrale par
exemple le directeur du Trésor le
directeur général de la police
national le le directeur général de
l'agriculture que sa enfin des grands
sujets d'action publique on définirait
la liste de ces postes et
automatiquement au fond après l'élection
présidentielle il serait remis en cause
et le nouveau pouvoirs renommerai en
toute transparence c'est le contraire de
la chasse aux sorcières chasse aux
sorcières c'est ce qu'a pratiqué
Hollande et Vals à partir de 2012 ils
ont décapité certaines des fonctions qui
pourtant étaient gérés par des gens de
grande qualité et de manière insidieuse
contourner là ce serait transparent on
définit le nombre des postes sur
lesquels le nouveau pouvoir légitime
issu des urnes souhaite avoir la main ça
veut dire ensuite et Eric notamment
parce et Claude parce qu'ils ont été au
gouvernement pourront l'expliquer ça
veut dire aussi qu'ensuite le ministre
il s'appuie sur une équipe rapprochée
dans laquelle il a toute confiance ça
veut dire aussi sans doute qu'il peut un
peu réduire la taille de son cabinet
parce que il y a plus besoin de
doublonnner par un conseiller technique
un service duquel on se méfierait un peu
et ça permettrait au ministrees d'avoir
un peu plus la main sur leur
administration on appelle ça le spoil
système aux États-Unis nous il s'agit
pas de copier les États-Unis ça sera un
spoil système à la française évidemment
mais ce serait de notre point de vue
assez important vous voyez ce sont pas
des bouleversements
idéologiques
ou constitutionnel majeur c'est plutôt
des ajustements pratiques pour que le
gouvernement ait plus d'efficacité plus
de capacité à délivrer des résultats au
service des Français c'est ça que je
voulais dire comme introduction à chacun
naturellement de de compléter je propose
peut-être que Claude s'exprime si elle
le
souhaite merci bravo Guillaume merci
tout
plein je crois que nous avions besoin
les uns et les autres d'une explication
claire
sur les articles qui gèrent le
fonctionnement de notre état merci
Guillaume d'avoir été aussi précis et
d'avoir donné tous ces éléments à à nos
amis aujourd'hui présents moi
j'essayerai d'être plus j'allais dire
plus concrète en tout cas ce que je vis
au quotidien lorsque j'entends Guillaume
dire que il est important que le
ministre puisse avoir une vraie
confiance dans son administration
j'atteste ce que tu ce que tu dis c'est
indispensable je j'ai pu m'en rendre
compte lorsque Nicolas Sarkozi m'a nommé
rire d'État à la famille il a fallu
lorsque je suis arrivé mettre en place
la feuille de route que m'avait donné le
président de la République qui avait été
confié par le Premier ministre et mon
rôle était à moi de mettre en
application ce que la feuille de route
du président de la République avait été
et et je me suis confronté à
l'installation d'une administration qui
était là depuis longtemps et qui avait
peu envie peut-être de voir évoluer les
choses et qui était absolument pas prête
à entendre la voix du ministre et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il a fallu de
nombreux conseillers pour que ces
conseillers puissent discuter avec les
différentes administrations donc bref il
faut aujourd'hui et je trouve ça
indispensable que le ministre ait
confiance en son directeur
d'administration quand je dis ça je
m'appuie aussi sur l'expérience qui est
la mienne aujourd'hui en tant que député
lorsque vous êtes député vous avez
besoin d'être en confiance avec vos
assistants parlementaires donc vous
choisissez vos assistants parlementaires
pour pouvoir travailler
dans une entreprise vous ne pouvez pas
concevoir que le chef d'entreprise est
un directeur qui fasse l'inverse de ce
que demande le chef d'entreprise et bien
dans la fonction publique et les
administrations il doit en être de même
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
extrêmement favorable lorsque le
ministre arrive dans un ministère il
puisse choisir le directeur de
l'administration qu'il va avoir à ses
côtés en permanence pour pouvoir
travailler en confiance et en cohérence
qui me semble tout à fait important
puisque le président de la République
veut de l'efficience donc ce choix me
semble indispensable et puis au-delà du
du choix je crois qu'il faut aussi qu'on
ait une forme de de respect vis-à-vis du
du du ministre qui est en place je
rappelle un peu cet exemple qui va vous
paraître fort mais il n'est pas rare que
des ministres a entendu se
dire vous êtes le train moi je suis la
gare en gros L'Express si on veut bien
dire vous vous êtes là pour un passage
moi administration je suis là pour
longtemps donc ce que vous me dites
finalement j'en ai rien à faire et je
fais ce que je veux vous voyez ce que je
vous dis je je vous l'explique par des
des propos très concrets mais qui sont
quand même la réalité et donc comme la
nature a horreur du vide il faut savoir
que si le politique lorsqu'il arrive
dans un gouvernement n'est pas
suffisamment fort et ferme et bien comme
la nature à horors du vide et bien ce
sont les administrations qui prennent la
place et qui dirigent malheureusement le
pays je dis pourquoi malheureusement non
pas que les administrations ne sont pas
euh efficaces parce que je ne suis pas
contre les administrations au contraire
ils sont très efficaces ils avent
exactement quels sont les moyens
techniques juridiques d'application de
ce que le ministre demande mais nous ne
devons pas oublier que l'action
politique est véhiculée par la volonté
la feuille de route du président de la
République que le ministre mettre en
application et que l'administration doit
être là à ses côtés pour justement
exprimer le fait de savoir s'il faut
modifier ou pas leur orientation qui est
qui est la nôtre voyez que les choses
sont aujourd'hui relativement concrètes
et c'est ce dont nous manquons
considérablement aujourd'hui dans notre
dans ce gouvernement qui gère notre pays
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui le politique
dit une chose l'administration dit le
contraire ce qui amène le politique à
dire évidemment l'inverse non avant
c'était le soir maintenant c'est le midi
donc on send bien compte que la force
politique l'orientation politique n
n'est pas là alors donc je suis et je
prêche pour que les directeur
d'administration puisse être nommé par
le ministre je ne demande pas à ce qu'il
soit évincé de l'administration mais
qu'il soit rediriger dans une autre
administration d'ailleurs je crois je
vous le dis avec grande sincérité je
crois que ça simplifierait beaucoup les
choses pourquoi d'abord pour les
administrations ça leur permettrait de
de s'enrichir professionnellement
puisqu'il ne seraient pas toujours dans
le même domaine cela leur permettrait de
connaître d'autres domaines et de ce
fait cela donnera évidemment beaucoup
plus de de possibilités d'action pour le
ministre qui se trouvera avec une équipe
qui l'aura organisé qui l'aura installé
et qui pourra travailler avec lui en
pleine confiance un autre point que un
autre point sur lequel je voudrais
insister Guillaume tu en as parlé ce
sont les autorités administratives elles
sont aujourd'hui devenues tellement
nombreuses juste pour exemple on n pas
loin de 40 agenceces commission
médiateur organisé aujourd'hui
indépendante quand même c'est quand même
considérable donc donc on se trouve avec
des doublons qui qui paralysent l'action
politique c'est ça qui est important
c'est l'action politique la direction
que le Président de la République veut
donner et bien c'est ces doublons
paralysseent il n'est pas rare le nombre
de fois où il a fallu que je discute
négocie avec ou agence administrative ou
service administrative pour qu'un projet
puisse exister en l'occurrence lorsque
je je j'étais secrétaire d'État à la
famille je voulais faire le mince le nom
m'échappe c'est le la préparation au
mariage civil quelque chose qui m'avait
été demandé par le président Nicolas
Sarkozi qui était une solution que nous
devions instruire pour que toutes les
personnes qui s'engageent dans le
mariage puissent savoir quelles étaient
leurs obligations ils ont des droits
bien sûr mais ils ont des obligations ça
a pris un temps considérable oseraai-je
dire pas loin de 9 mois tout cela parce
qu'il fallait que je négocie
pour arriver à ce sujet-là donc vous
voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui 9 mois oui
c'est quasiment presque une grossesse
mais c'était pas dans ce sens-là que je
voulais vous le dire voyez que cette
paralysie qui normalement ne devrait pas
exister parce que les administrations
sont tellement compétentes compétente
qu'elle pourrait faire avancer les
choses mais comme nous avons une volonté
politique qui n'est pas toujours en
concordance avec la volonté de des uns
et des autres et bien cela crée une
paralysie voire une illisibilité
et aujourd'hui les Français ne
comprennent plus du tout le
fonctionnement de notre de nos
institutions et de notre de notre
gouvernement voilà ce que je voulais
dire rappelez tout simplement que le
ministre que le cabinet du ministre doit
être le trait d'union entre le ministre
et les administrations que les
administrations ne sont pas là pour
imposer leur volonté mais justement pour
appliquer ce qui est demandé par le
président de la de la de la République
et puis je terminerai par un autre point
qui me qui me touche beaucoup en tant
que député aujourd'hui c'est que je me
rends compte que là encore une fois le
gouvernement méprise le Parlement quand
une loi est proposée par le gouvernement
elle doit être débattue par le Parlement
et bien je me rends compte
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes quasiment la
4e voire la 5e roue du Carros
c'est-à-dire qu'on consulte pierre
pauljacques plus les les les syndicats
bref tout le monde fait apporte sa
pierre à l'édifice finalement le projet
de loi du gouvernement n'a plus vraiment
ni que ni tête et on arrive nous par par
lement avec une obligation de remettre
et bien cette loi sur ses roues et
finalement on se rend compte
qu'aujourd'hui et bien le Parlement
n'est quasiment plus écouté donc il faut
remettre vraiment absolument le le la
loi là où elle doit être c'est-à-dire le
Parlement le fonctionnement du Parlement
et le fonctionnement du
gouvernement merci Claude on reviendra
tout à l'heure dans la table ronde de
Daniel sur la question du Parlement et
notamment de son format voilà je me
permet une incise je suis député depuis
4 ans j'aurais bientôt 40 ans moi à
titre personnel je considère qu'on est
beaucoup trop nombreux au Parlement et
qu'on pourrait faire un travail beaucoup
plus efficace de manière plus resserrée
plus
musclée Philippe Philippe RAMBAL
directeur donc des affaires publiques d'
et Yang
oui merci merci de me convier ici j'ai
j'ai la chance de pouvoir travailler en
tant que conseil consultant auprès du
secteur public donc je vais vous faire
part de mon expérience et puis j'ai eu
la chance de servir dans une vie
antérieur comme membre du cabinet de
d'Eric vert et ça ça a été une grande
chance aussi voilà donc j'ai une autre
j'ai une autre expérience
[Applaudissements]
aussi vous voyez ça mène à tout le fait
d'être en cabinet ministériel mais pour
être très sérieux parce que votre votre
sujet là est très sérieux je pense que
c'est important qu'on que que je
revienne avec vous sur des éléments
qu'on a obtenu parce que nous
travaillons beaucoup auprès de nos
clients du secteur public et nous
essayons de sonder régulièrement aussi
la population les français pour savoir
ce qu'ils attend
de nos clients de toutes ces agences de
toutes ces administrations et là on a
fait ça avec une qui s'appelle acteur
public et un institut sondage l'OP et il
y a un élément très frappant qui rejoint
vraiment les débats que vous avez ici
qui sont quelles sont vos attentes
principales vis-à-vis des
administrations vis-à-vis des
institutions la première chose qui nous
demande donc ce qu'on peut améliorer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut améliorer la
première chose qui demande c'est plus de
responsabilité plus de contrôle plus
d'évaluation donc ça va vraiment d'abord
dans ce sensl c'est faire en sorte que
toute la chaîne hiérarchique se sente
responsable de la politique qu'elle met
en œuvre et ça c'est plus de 50 % des
Français qui le disent et qui attendent
d'abord cela d'une administration au
service du politique le deuxième aspect
qui est très fort alors qu'on leura posé
beaucoup de questions c'est dire changer
le statut des fonctionnaires alors
probablement derrière ça c'est les
Français qui le disent vous pouvez
applaudir les français si vous voulez
mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est
très frappant parce que ça vient en
deuxè position alors probablement que
derrière il y a des des notions plus
larges qui sont diversifier l'accès à la
fonction publique changer le mode de
recrutement du top management et cetera
c'est une c'est une question un peu
large qui est qui est structurante mais
en tout cas elle vient en deuxè position
ça c'est vraiment très frappant et le
troisième élément qui est très fort
aussi c'est dire recentrer l'État sur
ses fonctions principales régaliennes et
donner plus de liberté de marge de
manœuvre aux collectivités local donc on
est vraiment entré dans une nouvelle ère
où les Français se rendent compte
manifestement attendent beaucoup plus et
et des éléments beaucoup plus concrets
tangibles et en terme de responsabilité
de leurs institutions du coup le le
consultant que je suis trouve que vous
abordez les questions d'une façon
vraiment intéressante puisque vous dites
si je veux faire avancer les
institutions quelles sont les questions
que je me pose d'abord le sens que vous
voulez leur donner et ça ça a été toutes
les tous les ateliers les tables rondes
que vous avez fait thématique sur les
différentes politiques au fond le sens
que je veux donner ensuite on se pose la
question du management qui va porter ces
éléments là c'est les questions que vous
posez sur qui jeun homme pour faire ça
et puis on se pose des questions
d'organisation quelle est la meilleure
organisation la plus efficace pour le
faire et c'est là où vous abordez cette
question du démembrement est-ce que la
mise en place de ces nouvelles autorités
qui sont plus de plus en plus nombreuses
est-ce que c'est un des éléments de
d'efficacité de l'action publique et
là-dessus quelques points peut-être
d'éclairage sur ces sur ces deux
questions que vous posez très clairement
d'abord sur le top management au sein de
l'administration française un des un des
points intéressants c'est effectivement
de comparer notre situation avec le
système américain parce qu'on a des
chercheurs qui ont travaillé là-dessus
et des chercheurs de pour la la
Fondation Fondapol qui l'ont fait et on
se rend compte de façon intéressante que
le système américain va très loin et que
on est en fait dans une dans des
discussions là presque de bon sens en
fait dans ce que vous proposer puisque
les Américains dans le système américain
sans aucune difficulté alors même que
c'est quand même des berceaux aussi de
la
démocratie vont jusqu'à faire en sorte
que de 3000 à 5000 parfois
fonctionnaires au fonctionna soit changé
jusqu'à 5000 fonctionnaires d'ailleurs
si vous le voyez dans le langage courant
souvent on parle de l'administration
Obama de l'administration Rean et cetera
c'est on confond un peu les deux parce
que ce n'est pas possible d'avoir un
gouvernement sous une administration qui
suiv qui mettent en œuvre sa politique
et c'est intéressant de voir ce vocable
là donc 5000 en France il y a des textes
qui définissent les emplois qui sont dit
à la décision ou à la discrétion c'est
dire à la décision du gouvernement mais
ça veut dire la discrétion il y en a à
peu près 500 et donc mais ce qui est
vrai c'est que c'est c'est ce sont des
textes qui ont d'abord vieilli qui sont
des textes niveau décret et probablement
que donner une force de loi organique
donnerait beaucoup plus d'impact de sens
clarifierait les choses politiquement
beaucoup plus fortement mais là on parle
de 500 personnes là où les États-Unis
ils sont à 5000 il y a une deuxième
différence c'est que dans le fameux
système des dépouilles le spoil système
américain nous avons bien des personnes
qui sont désignées souvent pour leur
affinité politique mais aussi parce
qu'elles viennent avec une expérience
différent et qu'elles ne sont pas toutes
des haut fonctionnaires et c'est ça une
des autres grandes différences majeures
et sur lesquell il peut y avoir une
attention aussi de votre part et je sais
que vous l'avez eu vous avez eu ces
questions dans vos travaux parce qu'on
se rend compte que en fait ils ont
énormément de personnes qui sont des
chercheurs à Harvard qui veulent mettre
en place une politique à laquelle ils
ont contribué avec les politiques qui
ont été élus ils ont aussi beaucoup de
chefs d'entreprise donc ils ont des gens
qui viennent du privé nous ernsteinung
notre patron Weinberger été avocat avant
de servir d'ailleurs sous deux
administrations différentes et puis est
revenu dans le privé donc ce sont des
éléments qui sont classiques habituels
et un chiffre à retenir dans une des
études
que qu'on a pu retrouver c'est que vous
avez dans les administrations
économiques aux États-Unis vous avez 60
% de ces postes de ces 5000 postes dans
les les postes principaux 60 % sont des
personnes qui sont issues du secteur
privé alors que dans l'administration
française dans le cercle Bery quand vous
prenez les cabinets et les directeurs
vous avez tout juste un quart des
personnes qui ont eu une expérience dans
le secteur privé c'est même pas venir du
secteur privé c'est avoir une expérience
dans le secteur privé donc ça c'est une
des premières différences une des autres
grandes différences on peut apprendre
aussi probablement aussi de cet exemple
c'est que nous avons la plupart de ces
personnes sont donc issu de l'EN en
France ou de Polytechnique et autres
c'est les à peu près les 2 tiers alors
qu'aux États-Unis il y a un/ers
seulement de ces haut cadres qui sont
issus de ce qu'on appelle l'IV League
c'est-à-dire les universités les plus
prestigieuses un/ers seulement contre
2/3 en France si on comparait les deux
systèmes donc on voit bien qu'on a on a
de la marge on a un décalage on a de la
marge et dieu sais que c'est une
administration américaine qui quand elle
veut y aller elle y va ils ont 4 ans en
plus ils ont un temps court pour agir
donc ils l'ont et donc probablement ce
sont des expériences qui peuvent nous
être utiles c'est vrai que de notre côté
on voit très bien ce que veut dire une
impulsion ou pas en matière de réforme
de l'État la façon dont on est gouverné
aujourd'hui ce qui s'appelle le
secrétariat général pour la
modernisation de l'action publi c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que ce que
c'était lorsque c'était la direction
générale de la modernisation de l'État
sous le gouvernement précédent on voit
bien que l'impulsion au plus haut niveau
est extrêmement importante pour la
diffusion d'une culture de réforme à
tous les niveaux de l'administration
ensuite donc il y a certainement
beaucoup de de de choses sur lesquelles
vous pouvez avancer là-dessus l'autre
point sur l'organisation c'est vrai
qu'on a un état où on a maintenant ce
qu'on appelle des autorités
administratives indépendantes c'est un
terme quand même très fort et c'est un
terme qui est en fait nouveau puisque le
Conseil d'État lui ne s'y est penché
qu'à partir du début des années 2000 et
d'ailleurs dans la catégorie de ces
autorités administrative indépendante il
a même estimé dans un rapport public le
Conseil d'État qu'il y en avait
certaines qui étaient indépendantes
parce qu'on les qualifiait ainsi alors
même qu'on peut avoir une hésitation
c'est écrit tel quel par le Conseil
d'État donc on voit bien qu'on est en
train de créer des nouvelles structures
juridiques dont on ne sait pas très bien
ce qu'elles ont comme format comme
niveau niveau de responsabilité et si
l'on revient à ce que demandent les
Français il faut savoir devant qui elles
sont responsables et probablement
là-dessus parce qu'elles sont
effectivement une quarantaine alors
elles étaient une trentaine il y a 15
ans maintenant elles sont une
quarantaine finalement ça fait quand
même un tiers de plus ça avance pourquoi
on crée des nouvelles alors que
peut-être celles qui existent sont
capables aussi de porter une partie de
ces missions alors certaines d'entre
elles sont exigées pour des question de
droit de la concurrence il y en a
probablement certaines dont on ne
maîtrise pas l'élément fondateur mais
pour beaucoup on peut vraiment se poser
cette question de comment on aborde la
protection des libertés publiques la
médiation la régulation il y a d'autres
façons d'agir et probablement que dans
les éléments très concrets qu'on peut
avoir si on fait ça par analogie avec ce
qu'on voit sur d'autres opérateur de
l'État c'est bien se poser la question
de savoir par quel niveau de texte ils
sont créés effectivement une des
propositions parce que les les
commissions du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale ont travaillé sur ces
questions là que ce soit pas n'importe
quel niveau texte qui puisse en créer
une est-ce que c'est systématiquement
une loi par exemple pour qu'il y ait un
vrai contrôle du Parlement dès le départ
qu'il y ait ensuite un deuxème élément
qui est une feuille de route claire
donné par le ministre quand même en
charge de la politique à cette
institution une feuille de route
clairement établie publique parce que
vous tous nous tous avons le droit de
savoir quel est le la direction donnée à
cette agence ce n'est pas neutre dans la
façon dont on contrôle les libertés
publicque dans la façon dont on régule
un marché parce qu'elles ont des
pouvoirs de sanction elles ont des
pouvoirs de réglementation aussi et puis
la troisième chose c'est qu'il y ait une
évaluation régulière par le Parlement si
on souhaite donner une certaine forme
d'indépendance par rapport au
gouvernement que l'évaluation elle-même
soit par le Parlement probablement qu'on
peut aussi l'organiser mais c'est vrai
que quelque part on est dans un nouveau
monde un peu comme il y a un siècle où
tout à coup on a vu se créer des
établissements publics alors on savait
pas trop s'ils étaient industriels et
commerciaux s'ils étaient administratifs
il y a eu des grands débats et puis ça a
mis du temps et tout à coup on s'est dit
ils sont là qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et
le politique s'en est saisi et a
commencé à en faire un élément
structurant de sa politique publique et
ça c'est vrai que c'est aussi un un
élément très fort qui est qui est devant
nous et que d'une certaine façon vous
assumez de prendre en compte dans dans
vos propositions et voilà c'était
quelques points d'éclairage que je
voulais vous apporter
merci merci infiniment juste un petit
mot de de complément sur le top
management de la fonction publique je
voudrais bien préciser une chose pour
que ce soit clair il s'agit pas du tout
pour nous de dire que les 2,5 millions
de fonctionnaires de
l'État devraient tous naturellement
quitter leur fonction au lendemain d'une
élection et devrai tous afficher un
engagement politique conforme à celui de
la nouvelle majorité pour être embauché
ça ça serait complètement contraire à
tous nos principes c'est absolument pas
ce qu'on propose on propose pas non plus
de s'aligner sur le système américain on
regarde ce qui se passe dans des pays
amis euh voisins mais il s'agit pas de
faire un copier-collé au fond il s'agit
de revenir au principe même de notre
République et je voudrais juste ça fait
une phrase vous lire l'article 15 de la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 l'article 15 c'est la
société a le droit de demander compte à
tout agent public de son administration
et donc ce que nous disons c'est que le
top
management 100 200 300 400 c'est bien à
préciser dans une loi organique il
faudra faire une liste très précise de
ces fonctions le top management il
quitte ses fonctions quand le nouveau
président est élu et c'est la nouvelle
majorité qui impulse qui nomme en toute
transparence c'est ça et c'est
uniquement
cela bon comme le dit euh comme le dit
Guillaume il y a pas de de de brutalité
dans ces changements que l'on que l'on
demande c'est juste de faire en sorte
que nos institutions puissent
fonctionner de la manière la plus
efficace possible et on voit bien que
nos citoyens ils ont beaucoup changé
depuis
1958 les d'abord d'abord
la démocratie a fait son son son ça
marche en avant c'est le besoin de
transparence est considérable les
progrès technologiques sont sont venus
bref la France d'aujourd'hui c'est plus
du tout celle du début de la 5e
République alors à la 5e République elle
a été beaucoup changé elle a beaucoup
évolué la première grande évolution
c'est l'élection au suffrage universel
du président de la République donc c'est
des changements considérables et on doit
continuer au fond à la faire évoluer
tranquillement mais mais fermement et ce
qui a été dit par Claude comme par
Philippe comme par Guillaume vont
évidemment dans ce dans dans ce sens moi
je voudrais rajouter deux trois choses
le premier c'est que la première chose
c'est que il faut arrêter de réformer la
réforme de l'État on passe son temps
comme comme on sait pas trop comment
réformer l'État on réforme la réforme de
l'État donc on s'est dit qu'on va faire
autrement on fait le contraire de ce
qu'on fait ceux d'avant qui en général
avait pas fait grand-chose en dehors de
du fait que lorsque c'était nous c'était
CIT pas le cas et les socialistes ont
passé un temps fou à s'occuper de la
réforme que nous avions nous-même mise
en œuvre on avait fait ce qu'on appelait
la
RGPP on avait essayé de baisser le
nombre de fonctionnaires tout ça c'était
pas une vision comptable des choses
c'était pas le fait de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un fonctionnaire sur deux
qui partte à la retraite et et qui soit
pas remplacé c'était simplement pour
donner des contraintes vous savez vous
réformer au fond que sous contrainte les
pays qui ont fait de grandes réformes de
leurs institutions de tous les jours je
dire et et donc de leur de leur de leur
état sont des pays qui l'ont fait
souvent sous contrainte c'est parce
qu'il y avait des crises gigantesques et
ça a donné parfois des réforme
extrêmement réussies et qu'on apportait
de manière emblématique mais il y avait
au départ une contrainte et donc on doit
se créer un certain nombre de contrainte
si on veut avancer il faut mettre de la
de la pression et il faut absolument
stabiliser les mécanismes de réforme de
l'État et il faut c'est vraiment un truc
où il faut une procédure un process une
manière de faire qui qui peut être
différente si on est de droite ou de
gauche parce que c'est quand même pas du
tout la même chose ça peut être
différent mais le process reste les
mêmes on rend compte on dit que telle
administration ou telle politique est
efficace ou ne l'est pas quand c'est pas
efficace on la change on passe pas son
temps à légiférer sur des lois inutiles
on essaie de faire en sorte que la loi
elle soit bien rédigée on vérifie la
vitesse de production des décrets
d'application et cetera et cetera et
tout ça c'est évidemment absolument
nécessaire et donc faut mettre en place
et stabiliser des outils de réforme de
l'État qui doivent être portés
politiquement et porté politiquement
notamment par un ministre important qui
doit pouvoir rendre compte au au
Parlement et rendre compte évidemment au
au gouvernement et ce qu'avait fait
d'ailleurs sans vouloir tomber dans une
séquence nostalgie ce qu'avait fait
l'ancien président de la République
enfin le dernier vrai président de la
République que nous ayons eu c'està-dire
Nicolas Sarkozi nous avons
nous avons ouais je c'est un peu facile
ça fait toujours ça fait toujours
plaisir ça fait toujours plaisir il
avait fait en sorte que tout toutes les
toutes les toutes les propositions de
réforme de l'État ell soient pas arrêté
dans une commission Théodule elle soit
passée devant le Conseil des ministres
donc il y avait un conseil des ministres
puis après il y avait un conseil de
réforme de l'État où tous les ministres
autour de la table entendaient les
propositions qui sont faites des
propositions souvent qui s appliquer à
leur propre ministère et ils étaient
censés évidemment les mettre en œuvre et
et censé s'intéresser au fonctionnement
de leur ministère par que souvent le
ministre comme il est là pour pas très
longtemps il s'intéresse pas au
fonctionnement de son propre ministère
il s'intéresse au fonctionnement de la
presse donc il essaie de de de de faire
en sorte qu'il y a un maximum de fois
son nom dans la presse puis à un moment
donné il veut s'arrêter parce que comme
maximum de fois c'est en général qu'on
dit du mal donc il essaie de stopper
cette machine infernale et tout ça ça
donne pas véritablement beaucoup de
fonds donc faut privilégier le fond et
le ministre il doit aussi s'occuper du
fonctionnement de son administration
moi j'en ai un peu assez avec ce que
j'appelle la République des parapluies
qu'on passe son temps à lever un
parapluie autour de sa au-dessus de sa
tête je sais bien que c'est évidemment
important là-dessus le président de la
République a inauguré ces changements
climatiques de façon forte et et c'est
durable et c'est durable et on le voit
on le voit sur ce sur ce sur ce
printemps pourri climatiquement et et
pourri politiquement et la République
des parapluies c'est grosso modo un
politique qui prend un minimum de
décision parce que les décision s'ffâche
et que plus il prend de décision plus il
est attaqué donc moins est dur donc
moins de décision beaucoup d'éléments de
langage beaucoup de propositions creuses
et puis on occupe le terrain des coûts
et des et des et des médias voilà et
puis de une administration qui en fait
le moins possible non pas qu'elle ait
pas envie de travailler je je n'accuse
en aucun cas les fonctionnaires j'ai une
opinion extrêmement élevée de la plupart
des fonctionnaires qui sont réellement
des serviteurs de l'État mais en même
temp ils ont pas envie de prendre des
responsabilités si au fond les
politiques les prennent pas et donc
l'administration bah elle met un deuxème
un troème parapluie le pauvre préfet en
bout de chaînne dans le département il
ose plus faire grand-chose au fond
aujourd'hui souvent un grand préfet
c'est un préfet qui fait rien avant à
l'époque Gauliste un grand préfet
c'était quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup
c'était quelqu'un qui était
l'interlocuteur principau principal des
des élus et qui aussi interprétaent les
textes il faut donner un pouvoir d'in
prétation et de souplesse parce que le
législateur à Paris il peut pas voir ce
qui va se passer dans nos principaux
départements il faut donc qu'il ait un
pouvoir d'interprétation ou de souplesse
des textes qui s'appliquent dans les
départements au plus près au fond et ça
il faut l'écrire il faut le dire puis
après faut avoir le courage de le faire
aujourd'hui entre le risque politique
que prendrait une administration qui se
mettrait à décider et puis le risque
pénal que prend parfois cette même
administration évidemment ça donne ces
énormes parapluies qu'on déploie adessus
de nos têtes et qui sont au fond la
République de l'immobilisme il y a un
deuxième point c'est que derrière cette
république des parapluies il y a aussi
l'idée que dans une démocratie il y a
des pouvoirs et il y a des
contre-pouvoirs il faut des pouvoirs des
contre-pouvoirs sinon il y a pas de de
démocratie mais juste simplement les
pouvoirs doit dominer le contre-pouvoir
parce que si le pouvoir ne domine pas le
contrepouvoir B plus rien ne fait
grandchose passer la marche arrière et
aujourd'hui en France le contrepouvoir
domine le pouvoir vous voyez par exemple
la les mécanismes de délivrance des
permis de construire et cetera au plus
près du du terrain vous voyez plus de
façon plus élevé un certain nombre de de
décisions tout à fait majeur il nous
faut 15 ans ou 20 ans pour construire
pour commencer à penser construire
Isabelle dans ta Bretagne le l'aéroport
de Notre-Dame des des Landes 50 ans on y
avait pensé avant qu'il y ait des avions
et tout d'un coup alors on a commencé
par un petit aéroport c'était à l'époque
de l'aviation héroïque et puis
maintenant comme on en est à des gros
avions à chaque fois on prend on perd du
temps donc on voit bien que le temps de
la décision politique n'est pas le temps
de la vie c'est pas le temps de la vie
donc on doit avoir un rythme d'exécution
de la décision politique qui soit
conforme au temps de la vie ça veut pas
dire qu'il faut prendre des décisions
dans la précipitation on a évidemment
besoin de peser le pour le compte de
comprendre d'étudier mais après il faut
y aller et souvent nos concitoyens sont
totalement perdus par ce temps énorme de
prise de décision public de la loi au
décret avec des décrets éventuellement
qui ne paraissent jamais tout simplement
parce que la loi elle est mal foutue
parce que les parlementaire s'amuse un
jeu extraordinaire qui est le faire en
sorte le chamboul tout des des
amendements il y a des amendements dans
tous les sens chacun y vare sa petite
idée parce que sa petite idée c'est au
fond ce qui arrange en général les
choses dans sa propre circonscription
mais pas nécessairement l'intérêt
national et que à partir du moment où il
y a des dizaines et des dizaines
d'amendements qui finalement sont vendus
ou voter le texte n'a plus grande n'a
plus grande cohérence et il est
impossible à appliquer et
l'administration se retrouve avec une
loi d'abord qu'elle a mit pas au début
faut l'admettre et puis après avec une
loi inapplicable donc elle est incapable
de prendre des décrets d'application et
tout ça ruine notre démocratie affaiblit
considérablement notre démocratie qui
devient impuissante et les Français ont
besoin de puissance politique ils ont
pas besoin d'impuissance politique et
très sincèrement je crois qu'en Europe
c'est exactement la même chose donc il
faut supprimer aussi a autorité et et
des autorités indépendantes parce que
d'abord elles sont pas indépendantes moi
je connais personne d'indépendant
personne n'est indépendante vis-à-vis
d'abord de soi-même de sa propre
carrière vis-à-vis du groupe auquel il
appartient en France on aime les groupes
on a fait à l'école on est les anciens
élèves on est sorti et cetera et cetera
donc il y a pas d'indépendance et la
véritable indépendance c'est l'élection
c'est le fait d'être élu à un moment
donné et de venir devant le peuple et et
de de de de faire son bilan et et de
proposer des choses pour l'avenir et et
je crois que la meilleure façon au fond
de retrouver de la puissance c'est de de
redonner la puissance c'est de recentrer
un certain nombre de décisions qui ont
été confiées par paresse ou par ou par
peur ou par manque de courage à des
autorité qui sont des des excroissances
d'un pouvoir politique mal compris donc
on doit retrouver de la puissance
politique supprimer un certain nombre de
Haute Autorité pas toutes bien sûr il
faut continuer à réguler il faut faire
mais en même temps ce terme
d'indépendant est extrêmement je trouve
extrêmement insultant pour le pouvoir
politique il y a d'un côté des gens qui
sont indépendants et donc qui finalement
sont honnê parce que c'est comme ça que
les choses sont prises et de l'autre la
décision politique qui serait par nature
malhonnête clanique pleine
d'arrièrepensée non moi je pense que les
nominations par exemple ne doivent pas
relever des autorités qui régulent elles
doivent relever du poouir politique dans
la transparence nos commissions
parlementaires peuvent jouer ce rôle
elles ont elles dev devrait jouer ce
rôle peut-être même devant les
télévisions pour que les auditions
soient publiques mais en même temps il y
a cette liberté de de choix enfin le
Parlement il doit contrôler l'action du
gouvernement il doit légiférer bien sûr
mais moins et il doit plus contrôler
l'action du gouvernement il est un
contrepouvoir mais à ce moment-là un
contrepouvoir politique ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose voilà ce que
j'avais envie de de de vous dire et et
je l'ai dit et je vous
remercie
bon Eric ver a eu raison de dénoncer la
République des parapluies je voudrais
rappeler que selon Pierre mandes France
gouverner c'est prévoir selon François
Hollande gouverner c'est
pleuvoir bien est-ce que vous avez une
question ou deux avant de passer à la à
la seconde table
ronde
merci
en fait ce ne sont pas des questions ce
sont trois axes d'amélioration qui me
permettra enfin qui qui qui semblerait
être mis en au travail voilà donc je
suis Michel adan je suis responsable de
la protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
sur le secteur de La Baule saint-nazer
et donc je pense que ce qui serait
important c'est que tous les
fonctionnaires soi obligés à la mobilité
dans leur carrière pas forcément à la
mobilité géographique mais à la mobilité
dans leur carrière et pouvoir bouger
d'un ministère à l'autre selon les
besoins de son administration que
d'autre part il faut que la fonction
publique évolue en même temps que le
secteur privé c'est-à-dire qu'il
faudrait que les petites unités
administratives comme la mienne puissent
se positionner comme de véritables
entreprises intéresser les
fonctionnaires au travail qu'ils font
d'une manière adapté au territoire et à
leur mission et d'autre part il me
semblerait utile aussi que les
directeurs de service et une véritable
formation initiale de gestion de
l'entreprise c'est une énorme carence
car effectivement il y a des gestions
qui se font en interne qui sont
intéressantes mais elles sont elles sont
pas suffisantes merci de sou elles ne
sont pas suffisante
[Applaudissements]
merci c'est c'est vrai c'est ce qu'on
découvre beaucoup dans nos dans nos
missions vous avez raison ça me fait
penser aut d'un d'un bouquin de Michel
CER qui s'appelait la société bloquée et
qui est paru en 71 il disait face à ce
l'administration de l'époque mais en
fait vous allez trouver des résonances
par rapport à ce que vous dites disait
il faut introduire de la mobilité de la
concurrence de la compétition et de la
négociation aussi que les gens puissent
aussi être acteur en fait de leur
carrière donc oui je pense que vous
serez un merveilleux terrain de
laboratoire manifestement pour la pour
la suite on prend encore deux questions
avant de passer à la seconde table ronde
monsieur
oui bonjour merci je m'appelle Philippe
Dieudoné je suis entrepreneur dans le
domaine de la performance des hommes et
des organisations et du développement à
l'international qui sont deux segments
qui sont éminemment preignants pour nos
pour nos entreprises et je voudrais
simplement porter témoignage en en 30
secondes j'ai participé la semaine
dernière au Conseil économique et
sociale et environnemental à une à des
grandes tables rondes qui étaent
organisé certes par le MEDEF oser le
Chang
et je dois dire que la table ronde à
laquelle j'ai j'ai participé qui
regroupait quasi exclusivement des des
entrepreneurs je v pas dire qu'elle a
repris mot pour mot mais presque toutes
les préconisations que vous venez
d'évoquer c'est vous c'est vous dire
combien finalement la société civile
dont on parle si souvent est en
résonance finalement avec notre avec
notre projet politique je voudrais
simplement donner une précision sur deux
éléments le premier on l'a on l'a très
largement évoqué là-bas et ici ce sont
les passerelles qu'il faut absolument
mettre en place entre le public et le
privé on est dans des cloisonnements
aujourd'hui qui sont absolument
mortifères et dans les préconisations
que nous avons fait au niveau de notre
table ronde on a dit la chose suivante
faire en sorte que les administrations
qui sont dans un cadre qui interviennent
dans un cadre régalien puiss être en
quelque Ste en quelque sorte
cristalliser dans leur mode de
fonctionnement actuel parce qu'ell
représentent
l'ossature finalement du pouvoir quel
que soient les alternances politiques
pour toutes les autres c'est le
changement et le changement maintenant
ça c'est le premier élément et puis il y
a un deuxième élément qui ne fait pas
l'objet finalement du débat de ce jour
mais qui est en résonance finalement
avec ce qui se discute aujourd'hui on
parle de la société civile qui est si
peu si peu représenté au niveau du du
pouvoir politique dans son sens le plus
large et là il y a une demande c'est
même quasiment une
exigence d'une meilleure représentation
de cette société civile dans les
différentes strates politiques et
évidemment ça met ça met en exerg et je
terminerai là-dessus toutes les
problématiques aujourd'hui que nous
connaissons à propos des
investitures OK non mais un élément de
réponse même sur le régalien même sur
les postes régaliens il peut y avoir de
la mobilité avec le privé ça peut avoir
du sens je parle sous le contrôle de
George fenc qui était là qu'un magistrat
judiciaire à la cinquantaine a été 5 ans
avant avocat ou professeur de droit
enfin il peut y avoir comme ça des allés
àretour dès lors qu'ils sont encadrés
qu' a pas de conflit d'intérêt et
cetera il y a eu vous avez complètement
raison il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de de
tentatives he ce Diagnos nostique de ça
manque un peu de de de de de porosité
entre le monde public et le monde privé
donc de de brassage de compéten et
cetera on le voit dans un sens
c'est-à-dire que les de très hauts
fonctionnaires parfois d'ailleurs de de
Bery aboutissent dans des grandes
entreprises et que les passerelles elles
sont dans un sens mais dans l'autre la
passerelle elle est souvent totalement
fermée pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est
que la première c'est que c'est que
c'est pas l'usage en réalité c'est pas
l'usage
et puis la deuxième se pose des
questions de rémunération aussi hein
souvent c'est que c'est pas tout à fait
les mêmes rémunérations donc les gens ne
le font pas puis se disent au fond
est-ce que moi j'ai une voix de de
sortie est-ce que je reviendrai dans
l'entreprise pas sûr du tout donc c'est
pas naturel parce que il y a beaucoup de
dangers à faire ça alors qu'il y a très
peu de danger de passer du public au
privé parce qu'une fois qu'on un
certains niveau on a on a peu de chance
de perdre au au change il faut qu'on
continue à travailler là-dessus c'est
sûrement une des clés il y a eu beaucoup
de tentatives c'est pour ça quand même
je tiens à dire a eu beaucoup de
tentatives elles ont plutôt échoué
jusqu'à
présent allez on prend une troisème
question et ensuite on passe la la main
à Daniel Fasquel monsieur
ah pardon bonjour à tous Maxens
strinquet 21 ans passionné par la
politique depuis mon plus jeune âge
auteur de quatre ouvrages dont le
dernier sorti la semaine dernière qui
traite justement de la réforme des
institutions alors je voudrais tout
simplement vous dire pour en
premièrement que je suis très heureux
d'être ici comme vous en tant militant
parce que je pense pas qu'il y a
beaucoup de partis où nous sommes
écoutés où nous pouvons débattre et je
pense que nous pouvons applaudir le
Président
Sarkozi alors je suis heureux pour une
deuxième raison parce que la plupart des
propositions que je fais dans ce livre
je les ai retrouvé aujourd'hui
concernant ce sujet alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a un manque d'autorité dans
notre pays qui a conduit à une défiance
envers les institutions la parole du
président de la République n'est pas
écouté président de la République
actuelle bien sûr n'est pas écouté euh
c'est pourquoi je propose que comme le
prévoit l'article 18 justement qu'il
soit qu'il puisse s'exprimer devant le
Parlement réuni en Congrès mais de
manière euh de manière régulière
c'est-à-dire une fois ou deux par an
parce que je pense que c'est beaucoup
mieux de s'exprimer devant la
représentation nationale plutôt que de
s'exprimer malgré tout le respect que
j'ai pour les journalistes de s'exprimer
devant les journalistes parce que on est
en élu 66 millions de Français on est
responsable devant les Français avant
tout alors ensuite permettre au
gouvernement de de pouvoir mener à bien
les mission qui est la sienne les
autorités administratives donc j'en
parle
aussi et le rôle des préfets dont on a
parlé et c'est vrai que les préfets ont
depuis quelques années un rôle de
pédagogie et je pense qu'il serait
nécessaire de l'étendre par des réunions
d'information publique avec les élus
afin de d'expliquer les réformes al ça
serait un lien entre l'administration et
entre l'autorité de l'État et les
Français puis je pense que je vais
terminer ici bon évidemment je parle
aussi du du Conseil économique social et
environnemental qui à l'heure actuelle
effectivement pourrait pourrait être
supprimé voilà mais
effectivement ou alors il faudra faire
deux choix soit le réformer soit le
supprimer voilà en tout cas je vous
remercie d'ord d'accord merci
aussi pour ton sens de la promotion donc
vous l'avez bien compris il a sorti un
livre hein c'est voilà les dernièrees
question bonjour messieurs alors moi
aussi je suis messieur et Madame
pardon madame
Claude euh donc moi je suis militant
depuis très peu de temps moins que
Monsieur euh je viens du sud de la
France parce que je vois que vous êtes
un peu blanc moi je viens de Toulouse et
ma remarque est tout à fait à propos
d'après ce que je viens de dire monsieur
vers euh a dit
[Musique]
que la politique de Monsieur François
bland c'était souvent la République des
parapluies j'an convienent très fort et
alors ma remarque c'était la République
des parapluis de Monsieur François
Hollande peut-elle un
jour dans pas longtemps faire place au
ciel bleu sans nuage de Monsieur Nicolas
Sarkozi
[Applaudissements]
c'est une vision poétique de la
politique et que j'aime
bien bien sur cette note pleine
d'espérance Daniel fascel va animer la
seconde table
ronde